let's unbox my Azure Standard grocery order for the next several months
for large items I got 25 pounds of rolled oats
25 pounds of all purpose flour
no actually
that's rice and 25 pounds of all purpose flour
sushi rice homemade egg noodles
to silly pasta 5 pounds of 8 spaghetti
almond flour cinnamon
three bags of late July sea salt
tortilla chips cinnamon sticks
cranberry juice concentrate
avocado oil vanilla extract
old fashioned molasses
raw honey apple cider vinegar
Worcestershire sauce sun dried tomatoes
canning lids mustard seed powder
chili powder cold raisins
apricot prunes
elbow pasta chia seeds
ghee
mini chocolate chips ginger
raw cheddar mozzarella
Munster Smokehouse Jack cream cheese
sour cream hummus
20 pounds of apples 10 pounds of onions
five pounds of carrots four pounds of grapefruit
let me know how much you think the total was in the comments